hey what's up guys quick question uh
josh park more towards you i got this
little uh
this little swag daddy over here yeah
he's a player
you know he's a stud he's probably gonna
mount a lot when he gets older
respect but uh he's the defiant one
i'm starting not to listen and i know
when he gets older
he's probably a little [ __ ] so i
want to know
you know in this this new world gage you
can't hit your kids anymore spank them
so josh what do you you know is there
any other ways to discipline them
i know timeouts for [ __ ] theo
you know we come from a different time
dude you know i'm sure you got spanked
when you're a kid do you actually
think it worked because when i was a kid
i remember i remember the beatings
i don't remember why i got the beaten so
i don't know if i actually learned
anything from it
so i don't know if you guys can give any
help
it would be appreciative thanks guys
gang
and uh yeah man yeah man
yeah man man well here's the deal
for a child that age it's hard for them
to understand
discipline and i
i i firmly believe especially that age
all physical does is instill fear espec
because you have no understanding at
that age you know what i mean
i didn't hit my kids um but i do think
every kid needs to be parented
differently like
if i have three older brothers where all
different people were all responded in
different ways
all my dad had to do was raise his voice
to me and i was like [ __ ] it that
i am good like i'm ready to do whatever
you need my brothers weren't that way
i will tell you this for me for my kids
and i think jacob is a good dude man
he's turned out pretty well yeah he
seemed like a really cool guy
um man there are things that they
here's the thing no you don't negotiate
with terrorists
they're all terrorists yeah you don't
keep
giving chances i i i always told my kids
here are the rules
you're not going to hear me tell you
again and warn you i just gave you
the warning is the rule so there's you
have to know they have to know oh if
this happens
i'm going to get in trouble right and
take everything
phone x you know these this generation
of kids thinks they're so tough
have you seen videos of people getting
their xbox taken or the oh
they try to i mean what's that crazy
video or that dude tried to shove the
remote control in his own [ __ ] he was
so mad at his parents for stealing his
they go crazy dude they're not gonna
just take the phone take the xbox
they lose their mind they don't know
what to do
no take what they love jacob one time
defied me because i told him no vapes
man i better not
ever see you with a vape this you never
saw this theo
oh my god i can't believe my mom just
canceled my brother's uh world of
warcraft account and he is
[ __ ] out dude a kid
[Applause]
i don't think it's fake because i don't
think kids are that good actors
look how crazy i don't know kids are
willing to be good actors because they
have no idea how ridiculous stuff looks
oh he's naked now after the sheep
[Applause]
oh my god here comes the come on greg
this oh my god
how primal huh
[Applause]
[Music]
now this kid needs his ass
this is when you beat a kid yeah man but
all i'm saying is
for me it's just a tantrum it's like a
watching a baby
you know but here's the deal dude so my
son tried to throw a tantrum
at a grocery store once my oldest son
trevor i left him
yeah i go hey man we don't do this in
public
and i go we're leaving he was like i'm
going to leave and i go cool i am
yeah i got jacob i got my daughter
we got in the car and we drove the [ __ ]
home what time did you get home
oh no no no i mean he was eight so i
didn't leave him leave him i drove
oh wow and then i drove back i see and
they were going crazy
like i came back i came back like 20
minutes later the other kid's like
you're leaving him yeah and i was like
yeah i'm leaving him and i go no
tantrums this isn't what we do
yeah i remember my dad left my my
brother for real
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you